[Music]
magic swirls all around us it is in the
air that we breathe do not be so naive
as to think we are the only ones who can
harness its power
[Music]
congratulations on your acceptance to
Belgrave University we have a question
what do you know about their medical or
the blue rose
everyone knows orders fake news you're
about to start the biggest adventure of
your lives what is we yeah it appears
you've been sullen
we're gonna take the call yes
they expect a great things from you
welcome to the order I'm gonna teach you
how to use magic properly a tutor you
got stuck with me for some reason just
lucky I guess there is a creature out
there that is tearing apart our recruits
this is being most powerful incantation
ever created what is it - anything is
possible if you do something people are
gonna die
we will build a world like you've never
seen
this is what you signed up for nothing
all magic has a cost if you don't pay
the price things could go wrong
[Music]
you